in 2017 jagannath not her real name had
the chance to start a new life away from
the armed group boko haram
then nigerian troops rescued her along
with other captives but she returned to
her husband a senior boko haram
commander based in some piece of forest
two months ago widowed and seven months
pregnant she went back to the city she
deserted
she had a miscarriage a week ago and the
fighters took away her other child
[Music]
those who returned and were rejected was
because of the destruction they caused
especially in the city of burma there
are too many who suffered great pain
because of boko haram their resistance
is understandable those who did the
murder and pillage are treated better
bana worked as a paramedic driver and
media man for the main boko haram and
its splinter allied with isil
forcibly enlisted at the age of 11 he's
back
his sister married to a boko haram
commander in sambisa is not
german
[Music]
you don't expect to be trusted when you
return from such misadventure people
will take their time before they trust
you i still fear the possibility of
being arrested and dumped in jail
in the last two months about six
thousand fighters and their families
surrendered due to renewed ground and
aerial offensive by nigerian troops
the nigerian military escalates
operations against boko haram and
infighting intensifies within the armed
group officials are preparing for the
surrender of more fighters and their
families however resistance among the
local population to reintegrate in them
is water in the government officials
here are concerned that if they're
pushed away it could prolong the
conflict
the united nations estimates that nearly
350 000 people died in boko haram
related incidents in the last 12 years
with entire villages destroyed millions
of people have been forced from their
homes
as hundreds of fighters began to desert
the group after the death of its leader
abubakar shekau the government has begun
reintegrating those forcibly conscripted
by boko haram and not the hardened
fighters
if we refuse to accept them
definitely you will join israel
we analyzed
and then weigh
the two different options
of receiving them
or not receiving them
but some victims of the conflict are
skeptical and that's a welcoming
the last thing we want is a return to
the time when gunfire and bomb
explosions were commonplace you can't be
certain that these people have repented
already hundreds of thousands of people
have been returned to their towns and
villages being rebuilt by the government
for now officials seemed determined to
speed up the process of rebuilding trust
hoping it could break boko haram's
fighting spirit and bring lasting peace
to the northeast ahmed idris al jazeera
maiduguri nigeria